ça fait 17 ans que joseph sepp blatter
président de la fifa et ça fait sept ans
que la controverse
il colle à la peau en 2002 le président
de la fédération somalienne l'accuse de
lui avoir offert 100 mille dollars afin
qu'ils votent pour lui quatre ans plus
tôt le suisse de 79 ans a gagné ces
élections quatre fois dont une par
acclamation en entrevue à radio canada
en août dernier sepp blatter s'était
défendu d'être corrompu vous parlez de
corruption donnez-moi soutien est une
preuve et puis personne n'a jamais
trouvé une preuve on a vu peut-être des
gens qui sont mal comportés à
l'intérieur de la fifa mais pas le
président
l'emprise de blatter sur la fifa est
totale l'ancien joueur diego maradona
l'a même comparé à un dictateur
ayari shipshaw menétrey tout même si la
terre accepter la critique sans broncher
cette semaine rappelant qu'il était
encore président et qu'il disait aussi
que mandat sepp blatter diriger une
fédération comptant 200 9 membres
c'est plus que l'onu et que seuil haut
chaque nation peu importe sa taille xl
un vote à l'élection présidentielle et
justement selon plusieurs de ses
détracteurs
c'est avec le vote des petits pays que
blatter métier son emprise la fifa est
investi des millions de dollars pour des
projets de développement du soccer
sepp blatter comptait beaucoup d'appuis
dans la concacaf la confédération
régionale de soccer représente en
amérique du nord centrale et les
caraïbes
la région compte 35 pays dont le canada
mais aussi les îles caïmans d'où est
originaire jeff le web pour président de
la concacaf et vice-président de la fifa
un proche de blatter aujourd'hui au
nombre des accusés
ici en temps des réseaux canada au real
j'accueille maintenant notre collègue
revers croisé qui suit depuis longtemps
la fifa et la corruption ça fait
longtemps qu'on en parle
robert c'est vraiment toute la planète
foot la cathédrale est aujourd'hui parce
que la fifa s'est beaucoup de pouvoir et
ça brasse beaucoup d'argent
oui c'est son précédent parce qu'on
parle bon là juste pour l'afro 250
millions de dollars
mais c'est aussi les milliards
qu'engrangent cette fédération
j'irai de manière régulière et depuis
des décennies alors c'est sans précédent
dans le monde du sport un scandale comme
celui là qui touchent en plus les hauts
dirigeants là on est carrément
pratiquement en haut de la pyramide avec
des président de confédération
c'est pas rien du tout et de mémoire
j'ai pas j'ai pas vu un scandale qui
pouvait à côté le scandale qui frappe
aujourd'hui à fifa et comme le disait
lamellaire responsable du département de
la justice américaine
on en est qu'au début vers d'autres
accusations sont à venir
il y en a pas contre contre sepp blatter
par ailleurs des accusations pour le
moment mais est-ce que ça démontre pas
encore une fois ce qu'on le vit
aujourd'hui que le sport ne peut pas
s'auto réguler lui même quoique ça prend
quand même des autorités judiciaires
c'est clair c'est clair et on l'a vu à
chaque fois systématiquement que ce soit
dans le dopage je repense à lance
armstrong où c'est le fbi qui a enquêté
mais à chaque fois on sait que c'est où
la police ou la justice qui vient régler
le problème du sport en l'occurrence la
ccan encore une fois une enquête du fbi
a alors on se dit que toutes ces
associations sportives n'arrive pas même
le comité international olympique
n'arrive pas à faire le grand ménage
mais faut dire aussi que ce sont des
associations qui sont opaques qui le
conte qui le rendent de comptes à
personne ce sont finalement des ddos bl
ce sont des associations à but non
lucratif qui gère des milliards de
dollars qui ne payent pas d'impôts en
suisse et qu'il loue à rendre aucun
compte publiques à l'état suisse c'est
ça qui est quand même incroyable et qui
ont le même statut en fait qu'un club de
pétanque ou de bridge quoi ouais bon
parlons de la suite pour sepp blatter
donc qu'est-ce qui est ce qui peut
vraiment se faire réélire vendredi avec
les accusations qu'on connaît maintenant
c'est un vieux renard il n'est pas
encore touché directement
c'est un vieux renard au même titre que
les terres juan antonio samaranch du
temps de dire que des corruptions
notamment le scandale de salt lake city
il est passé à travers toutes les
tempêtes
sepp blatter fait exactement la même
chose et en même temps comment il fait
beau il fait exactement ce que faisait
ceara rome où on antonio samaranch avec
le comité international olympique
il a sa garde rapprochée une garde qu'il
a bâti avec des soutiens étatiques dans
un certain nombre de continents et il
sera difficile à détrôner finalement et
si l'élection a lieu vendredi
je suis convaincu qu'il va être réélu
il ya quand même des négociations toutes
sortes de choses qui se passe en
coulisse moment non on ne sait pas on
sait moi j'aimerais être une [ __ ] il
sourit c'est sûr que je ne sais pas ce
que détient encore le département de la
justice américaine c'est à dire que
est-ce que ils détiennent des preuves
contre le plus haut sommet de la
pyramide dont contre le président ça
sera à voir et ça ça pourrait être
effectivement dommageable en attendant
les européens par exemple demande le
report carrément de l'élection de
vendredi
alors à suivre oui